Je suis fière d'être une femme et une féministe.
Cette publicité a été diffusée avec le slogan
de ce liquide vaisselle et le
slogan disait que les femmes de toute l'Amérique se
battent contre des casseroles et des poêles grasses. Ce dont
je me souviens le plus, c'est de parler
à une personne âgée très dynamique qui était
multitâche.  qui a compris que sa
voix contribue à beaucoup de
conversations
[Musique]
l'égalité ça veut dire que le secrétaire général de l'ONU
ban Ki-moon est l'égal du jeune stagiaire
à l'ONU qui rêve de
lui serrer la main ça veut dire qu'une femme ça veut dire
qu'une  la femme est l'égale de son mari, la
sœur de son frère, ni mieux, ni
pire, ils sont égaux
[Musique]
bien sûr, c'est décourageant, tu sais, en
fin de compte, je suis vraiment juste fier
de qui je suis et d'où je viens et nous  nous
ne nous sommes jamais
concentrés sur ce que nous sommes en tant que couple
[Musique]
il n'y a pas de meilleur moment que de vraiment
continuer à mettre en lumière les femmes qui
se sentent autonomes et les personnes qui les
aident vraiment à les soutenir,
vous le ferez souvent  J'entends les gens dire que vous
aidez les femmes à trouver leur voix et je suis
fondamentalement en désaccord avec cela parce que les
femmes n'ont pas besoin de trouver une voix, elles
ont une voix, elles ont besoin de se sentir habilitées
à l'utiliser et les gens doivent être
encouragés à écouter.